wir haben ein wichtiges Gesetz gerade im
Kabinett auf den Weg gebracht
ähm wir sorgen dafür dass Menschen ohne
Bleiberecht schneller unser Land
verlassen wir sehen einen Bündel
restriktiver Maßnahmen für mehr und
schnellere Rückführungen vor das ist
notwendig damit wir weiterhin unserer
humanitären Verantwortung für die
Menschen gerecht werden können die wir
vor Krieg und Terror schützen müssen wie
z.B auch die 1,1 Millionen Menschen aus
der
Ukraine um das Grundrecht auf Asyl zu
schützen müssen wir aber irreguläre
Migration deutlich begrenzen wer kein
Bleiberecht hat muss unser Land wieder
verlassen die Zahl der Rückführung ist
in diesem Jahr schon um ca 27% höher als
im
Vorjahreszeitraum dennoch gibt es
erheblichen
Handlungsbedarf unsere Neuregelungen
werden in einer Vielzahl von Fällen die
Möglichkeit für die Rückführung
verbessern dabei ist es mir besonders
wichtig Straftäter und Gefährder
konsequenter und schneller abzuschieben
das gilt besonders für die organisierte
Kriminalität die wir damit noch
entschiedener bekämpfen so wird die
Ausweisung von Mitgliedern krimineller
Vereinigung deutlich erleichtert und
unabhängig von einer individuellen
strafgerichtlichen Verurteilung bei
hinreichenden Tatsachen die eine
Mitgliedschaft in der kriminellen
Vereinigung belegen ermöglicht dies ist
ein weiteres Instrument zur Bekämpfung
von Strukturen der organisierten
Kriminalität wir gehen mit diesem
Entwurf insbesondere auch die von den
Ländern und Kommunen geäußerten
Bedürfnisse ein ich will nur noch mal
daran erinnern dass bei dem zweiten
Gipfel den wir hier im Haus hatten
dieser Prozess auch vereinbart wurde
zwischen den Ländern und Kommunen dass
wir nach tatsächlichen rechtlichen
Änderungsmöglichkeiten uns miteinander
austauschen und diese sind in diesem
Gesetzentwurf mit ein eingeflossen und
ein weiterer Nachvollzug ist der
Beschluss der gemeinsamen Konferenz des
Bundeskanzlers mit den
Ministerpräsidenten insofern ist das
beides in diesem gesetzgebungspaket drin
eines der großen Themen für die
Begrenzung der irregulären Migration ist
die maximale Bekämpfung der brutalen
rücksichtslosen und auch skrupellosen
schleuserkriminalität auch hier bringt
uns der heutige Beschluss voran wir
werden künftig Schleuser leichter aus
weisen können zudem sorgen wir dafür
dass künftig auch die Schleusung von
Kindern strafbar ist ich habe darüber
hinaus auch bereits weitgehende
Vorschläge vorgelegt damit wir von den
viel zu niedrigen Strafen für Schleusern
endlich wegkommen dazu strebe ich an
dass wir die Mindeststrafen und die
Höchststrafen für Schleuser erhöhen ganz
besonders bei gewaltsamem Vorgehen sie
erinnern sich an den furchtbaren Vorfall
zwischen der bayerischen
österreichischen Grenze ich hoffe dass
ich das Kabinett Anfang November mit
diesen Strafverschärfung weiteren
Strafverschärfung für Schleusern dann
auch beschäftigen wird vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit wir haben jetzt noch
einen kurzen Moment Zeit für ein paar
wenige Fragen
bitte in den Stellungnahmen zu Ihrem
Paket gab es zwei Stoßrichtungen einmal
GDP in die Richtung wir haben gar nicht
das Personal für das alles z.B Flüge zu
begleiten und so weiter und die zweite
Stoßrichtung Caritas pRO ASYL die
einfach sagen krasse Eingriffe in
Privatsphäre wie stehen Sie zu diesen
beiden Kritikpunkten die da in den
Stellungnahmen immer wieder kamen also
wir haben ja einen ich habe ja darauf
hingewiesen einen sehr langen Prozess
gehabt mit denjenigen die die
Verantwortung tragen sie wissen dass die
Abschiebung von den Ländern organisiert
werden müssen insofern trifft das vor
allen Dingen dort auch Landespolizei
aber auch Bundespolizei wir werden alles
dafür tun dass wir und das haben wir in
den letzten Jahren im Bund ja auch
gemacht Kräfte bei der Polizei erhöhen
um den vielfältigen Aufgaben auch
gerecht zu werden diese Maßnahmen sind
aber notwendig wir haben im Moment einen
ähm sehr hohen ähm ja Zulauf äh von
irregulärer Migration dieses Jahr gehabt
und deswegen müssen wir als Staat
handeln die Leute schauen zurecht darauf
wie handelt ein Rechtsstaat die
maßgeblichen Veränderungen ähm beim
Zuzug über die Route über Westbalkan
oder über das Mittelmeer werden bewirkt
über die europäischen Lösungen die wir
Gott sei Dank erreichen konnten aber
kurzfristig brauchen wir Maßnahmen und
das ist auch meine Antwort auf
diejenigen die Humanität natürlich
einfordern aber wir haben strikt darauf
geachtet dass wir ja für diejenigen die
unser Asylrecht brauchen dann auch
genügend Kapazitäten haben und genau
dafür machen wir auch die Einschränkung
her
sie Frau Ministerin die Grünen sind mit
dem Gesetzentwurf nur bedingt
einverstanden und sagen das müssen wir
noch prüfen im parlamentarischen
Prozess wo sehen sie denn noch
Veränderungsmöglichkeiten oder oder
Punkte an denen sie die grün den Grünen
möglicherweise Entgegenkommen könnten
und könnten sie noch zwei Sätze sagen zu
der Äußerung des unionsfrak
stellvertretenden
unionsfraktionsvorsitzen Jens Spahn der
Flüchtlinge zur Not mit physischer
Gewalt von Europa fernhalten will also
das geht natürlich rein rechtlich gar
nicht also deswegen das ist meine
Kommentierung dazu ansonsten lasse ich
mich da nicht näher drauf ein ähm ich
will vielleicht noch mal weil sie gesagt
haben die Grünen
vielleicht noch mal einmal ausholen das
ist ja kein feserbeschluss heute sondern
ein Beschluss des bundeskabinettes und
da sitzen die Grünen ja auch mit am
Tisch und Frau berbock und Herr habbeck
und Herr östemier und Frau Lempke waren
ja alle da heute und haben das
mitbeschlossen
insofern kann man nicht von den Grünen
sprechen ich glaube was wichtig war im
Vorfeld und deswegen ist es auch ein
gutes Signal wie gut dieses Kabinett
diese Bundesregierung arbeitet ist dass
wir im Vorfeld sehr darum gerungen haben
welche sind die besten Wege um
einerseits effektiv irreguläre Migration
auch zurückdringen zu können auf der
anderen Seite selbstverständlich unser
humanitären Verantwortung gerecht zu
werden und auch für die Menschen die
hier sind die möglichst m Integration
auch bekommen z.B durch einen früheren
Arbeitsbeginn den werden wir auch
ermöglichen das werden wir nächste Woche
im Kabinett auch verabschieden und ich
glaube dann ist es ebenso wie alles
andere ein sehr rundes Paket wir haben
ja uns schon im Koalitionsvertrag darauf
geeinigt dass wir auf der einen Seite
legale Migration ermöglichen wollen ohne
dass Menschen im Mittelmeer sterben
müssen auf der anderen Seite aber viel
mehr ordnen und Steuern deswegen
entsprechen diese ganzen Maßnahmen
angefangen vom
chancenaufentalsrecht über das
Fachkräfte Einwanderungsrecht über die
Staatsangehörigkeit und jetzt mit dem
großen Paket zu den rückführ genau dem
Geiste des Koalitionsvertrages den wir
ja gemeinsam verabredet haben dazu
stehen wir auch gemeinsam und deswegen
gilt auch noch mal mein Dank an beide
Koalitionspartner ausdrücklich für
diesen wirklich sehr guten zugewandten
Prozess in den letzten Wochen wie wir
jetzt zu dieser Einigung über dieses
Paket und über den früheren
Arbeitsbeginn von auch den Menschen die
schon bei uns sind gekommen sind
fr ja sie haben gesprochen Abschiebung
dafür braucht es aber ja auch Abkommen
mit Ländern das ist nicht so einfach
können Sie uns no mal die Schwierigkeit
erklären und mit welchen Ländern sie da
vielleicht schon in Kontakt stehen zur
Abschiebung und dann hätte ich noch eine
Frage zur aktu zur Einschätzung der
aktuellen Gefährdungslage
Islamisten im
Moment mache ich gerne sie haben zurecht
die Erarbeitung von
migrationspartnerschaften
migrationsabkommen angesprochen da
arbeiten wir ja permanent dran wir haben
das erste hatten wir geschlossen mit mit
Indien bereits letztes Jahr wir haben
einen sonderbevollmächtigten für
migrationsabkommen Dr Joachim Stamm mit
dem werde ich nächste Woche auch
gemeinsam nach Marokko Reisen ich glaube
das wissen Sie um auch an diesen
migrationsabkommen zu arbeiten
das ist ein bisschen heikel mit manchen
Staaten die nicht wollen dass wir
darüber reden aber ich kann ein paar
nennen mit denen Herr stamp und wir im
Austausch sind über diese
migrationsabkommen das ist die Republik
Moldau das ist die Republik
Usbekistan das ist die kirkisische
Republik der die Republik Kenia und
Republik Kolumbien das sind aktuell
Länder mit denen wir über diese äh
migrationsabkommen äh diskutieren und
beraten und hoffentlich auch zu einem
guten Ergebnis kommen
ähm ach so aktuelle Gefährdungslage ähm
aus unserer Sicht wir beobachten das
sehr genau gerade jetzt in diesen Zeiten
äh was die Gefährdungslagen bestimmt wir
haben gesehen dass es Ermittlungserfolge
gibt in einzelnen Bundesländern sie
sehen also dass alle Sicherheitsbehörden
da im Moment sehr alarmiert sind sehr
umsichtig umgehen wir haben keine
erhöhte konkrete Gefährdung die uns das
BKA mitgeteilt hat aber wir arbeiten
daran dass wir alles trotzdem sehr genau
gerade in diesen Tagen im Blick haben
genau dann
DAH gupser Schweizer Fernsehen
die Frist für die verschaften Kontrollen
an der Schweizer Grenze die läuft morgen
aus wird Deutschland die äh beantragen
weiterzuführen für die nächsten 10 Tage
ja wir werden die Verlängerung für
weitere 20 Tage so ist der Schritt dann
das ist erstmalig 10 Tage dann kommen 20
Tage danach wäre die Überlegung ob man 3
Monate verlängert das wird dann aber neu
lagerabhängig entschieden aber wir haben
mit unseren Nachbarstaaten gesprochen
und wir werden eine Verlängerung jetzt
auf jeden Fall
machen fre
Frage dankeön schön guten Tag h Genius
dpa mich würde interessieren Kanzler
Scholz hat im Spiegel erklärt wir
müssten im großen Stile Abschieden sehen
Sie das durch diese Maßnahmen gedeckt
sehen Sie jetzt die große Abschiede auf
abschiedeoffensive dadurch also Kanzler
Olaf Scholz hat ja in dem
spiegelinterview genau die gleiche
Ausgewogenheit auch an den Tag gelegt
wie ich sie gerade beschrieben habe
nämlich mit dem Gesamtpaket bei der
Migration er hat auch von Chancen
aufenalt über Fachkräfte Einwanderung
staatsangehörigkeitsrechten auf der
anderen Seite verstärkte Abschiebung
und ja selbstverständlich ist gerade
dieses Gesetzespaket heute Grundlage für
das spiegelinterview des Bundeskanzlers
gewesen dann haben wir hier
noch ich habe das spiegelke auf dabei
wollte auch noch mal zu der Aussage
Fragen der Bundeskanzler fordert endlich
mehr Abschiebungen ihr geswurf ist zu
entnehmen dass 600 Abschiebungen mehr
pro Jahr erwartet werden ist das was mit
im großen Stile mehr Abschiebung gemeint
ist oder was sie gerade gesagt haben in
einer Vielzahl von Fällen wo mehr abie
möglich sein sollen also wir haben ja
dieses Jahr schon 27% erhöht Rückführung
Abschiebung also das ist ja schon sie
sehen dass wir da mehr hinterher sind
und ich glaube worum es geht ist in
diesem Gesetzentwurf und deswegen ist er
so groß so breit dass es verschiedende
Maßnahmen sind also zum einen bei der
Bekämpfung verschiedener
kriminalitätsarten bei der Schleusung
bei organisierter Kriminalität dass wir
dort die Möglichkeiten schaffen auch
abzuschieben was wir bishang so in
diesem Maße noch nicht konnten da haben
wir jetzt die rechtlichen Voraussetzung
für und auf der anderen Seite aber die
Erleichterung bei den normalen
Abschiebungen nämlich
bürokratische Hemmnisse und wenn die
alle abgebaut sind und alle Beteiligten
dann entsprechend arbeiten dann werden
wir sicher mehr hinbekommen genau dann
haben wir noch Zeit für eine allerletzte
ganz kurze Frage
Frau jetzt habe ich noch eine Nachfrage
bei den vielen Aufgaben die sie jetzt
alle noch mal aufgezählt haben Herr
kopelker hat dann Herrn Scholz ein Brief
geschrieben der GdP Vorsitzende
Sondervermögen innere Sicherheit analog
inne zuur Bundeswehr was halten Sie denn
davon also ich glaube es ist angemessen
dass man dieser Tage auch
haushaltererisch auf die Herausforderung
reagiert ich bin dazu im guten Austausch
mit allen Beteiligten ich glaube dass
wir dafür auch gute Lösungen finden
vielen Dank noch mal für ihr Kommen
danke ihnen kommen sie gut nach Hause
danke schön fürs Kommen vielen Dank für
Ihr
Interesse